[Music]
so
as you have all may have heard disney
world is now
open well actually this very very moment
but i know that it has opened
i know they're housing the nba really
mm-hmm and so i've never been there me
neither i want to go awesome
it's the same as the one that's here
don't insult
me no it's not what the [ __ ] why what's
the same
it is so not the same what's the
difference between land and world
because land it's like more like it's
like more like
like smaller like it's a small world
after all yeah
it's more it's more humble disneyland is
like condensed milk
yes and then disney world is like milk
milk
it's big like space and everything like
that
space because florida got cheap land the
castle is big way bigger than disneyland
because disneyland feels [ __ ] big to
me already oh yeah disney world is like
way bigger i'm gonna have to go i'm
gonna have to go go go because i still
haven't even been a california adventure
what not once no i've never been a
california adventure
you've never easily never soared over
california that's not even an option
anymore yeah you can't soar over
california now it's like soaring over
the whole world
yeah that's good it's pretty fun i never
did it
and you can't do tower of terror anymore
it's just like guardians of the galaxy
it's better though
yeah power is just a drop right anyway
not anymore
not anymore it's pretty scary now i i
think the guardian of the galaxy one is
way better now
it's because it's it's a ride now it's
like it's throwing you around oh [ __ ]
yeah i might have to go check it out
because it's just like a giant jack-off
human being
you're the hand that goes up and down
the shaft of a dick
the one ride that i always avoided was
the ghost ride
i couldn't do it first of all ghost ride
you're talking about haunted mansion
yeah i think it was knott's berry farm
the haunted mansion i did it one time
and the whole time my eyes were closed
the one that like wondering you slowly
just turn around like this 23 years old
now
i was about 13.
that's too old i know right why is it
because of the ghosts
was in the mirror and like the ghost was
right next to you yeah i was in my i
think it was with my cousin or something
he just [ __ ] me up or somebody [ __ ]
me up i think it was my grandma i don't
know somebody [ __ ] me up
i forgot who it was but then uh yeah
when i was a kid too my grandma forced
me to go on all the roller coasters with
her
and i started to love it but that was
that one ride
i think i don't even know why we got on
it because she refused because she's so
christian but we want
went on it anyway and i just closed my
eyes the whole time
and then we got out oh man also you
don't even know if you don't like it
well cuz you go
in well i went on it now i like it but
then you go in right you know there's a
[ __ ] room that changes
oh yeah and it becomes the first thing i
said was
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i'm just gonna hold on to
somebody's shoulder
your grandma was like what did you say
how did you laugh at someone's shoulder
was it before they had like they they
took you in cars like how did that work
because you have to go to the elevator
and then you just
you just close your eyes and then they
take no windows
and no doors and then you go and then
you wait for the lot ride and you get on
and when you get on the ride i was just
like this
oh you turned and [ __ ] yeah there's that
one moment you're like
[Laughter]
you're not spinning yourself in the
mirror there's a [ __ ] ghost
yeah okay anyway so this story here
uh so there's this youtuber known as
that crazy disney lady
and she she ended up streaming her
visit with a friend back to disney world
and that's when uh it's like a four hour
youtube video because it's like
streaming it right so then during that
time
the friend ended up having some sort of
reaction
and people were speculating and
thinking like wait did these [ __ ]
come to disney world with
kobit oh [ __ ] she had corona
so that's what that's what speculators
were speculating but why did they think
she had corona because she was coughing
she had low blood pressure she was
vomiting like it was
she was vomiting in the stream what like
the livestream oh the livestream
she went to the yeah and stuff so i'm
going to play a clip
of when she's having this type of
reaction and like i said it's a
four-hour thing so it's just like are we
watching her just throw up
no see she went to the bathroom
all right here we go can you breathe
yeah it's just my throat feels very
nutty yeah did you say nuts on the menu
dude
i'll be fine she had a brownie or
something
ice cream it would be worse by now if it
was is there any kind of nuts in the
convolution
oh she had a nut reaction a nut allergy
contraction
oh she didn't she was literally
time to get some epipen going i'm good
i'm okay
since she's starting to have a funny
feeling i've got my
epipen if i need it so what are we
supposed to do i gotta wait and see
that's a very what we should do is go
over the medical center and get a
benadryl
yeah yeah let's do that that's a really
high quality screen
i'm sorry if not probably because
there's way less people using the
bandwidth there
damn i feel bad for her she's allergic
to nuts
[Laughter]
those really you guys are children wow
yes
yeah so people are oh because then she
ends up like
recording like you know they or she's
fine
well they go to the medic thing and then
they the
when they're there they're recommending
that she goes to the hospital
and so she was like no no i'm okay he's
just an allergy right all i need is a
small world
yeah you got another ride i just need a
teacup ride i'm gonna spin it right out
of myself
and then so the fact that she she denied
or like she
refused to go to the hospital people
were like the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] bank is being irresponsible
like she's not doing what
is being recommended she wants her
disneyland yeah
so so anyway so then that's when uh
so someone on twitter named jenny
nicholson she
ended up sharing a clip of the women to
her 157
000 followers on twitter and then that's
how it spread
like wildfire and so she was just saying
like you know this is what she said i'm
not saying the channel name and i'm not
inviting anyone to go harass these
ladies if they find it i'm sure
they're nice ladies who think they're
invincible and everything's good but
this is why theme parks shouldn't be
open
in a pandemic like that's kind of like
the bottom line for a lot of people that
are upset about this because they're
like
do you see the risks like people are
like we're
we're going to these establishments on
an honor honor system
and what if she really is sick even
though she thinks it's an allergy
reaction but then every
she's putting everyone else in in danger
and
that's kind of like the real discussion
here
are they what are what are they doing
like are they doing the whole
temperature check and all that stuff
they are doing the best that they can to
make sure everyone's staying safe like
for
whatever standards that have been
announced but
a lot of people are against even just
that it's just like why
even risk it our numbers are so [ __ ]
high right now like
disney world should not be open it's not
florida's like
a big hot spot right and they just never
closed really
right i'm so torn because like on one
side i understand
businesses they're just trying to come
back asap so they don't end up
dying permanently yeah so they need
revenue but then on the other side i'm
like but it's also
not like it's a not an essential
business you know it's like a fun
business
so that's what you're telling me dreams
aren't essential they are
mickey mouse is very essential but i'm
like damn
did you guys see the clip of the first
day disneyland was open the um
there was a you know the brave girl like
a princess yeah she was riding on the
horse through the
through the park that's right yeah yeah
yeah
and then like some little girl threw her
balloon at the horse
she's like three or something whatever
yeah through the balloon with the with
the
little tight end that has a weight yeah
you got stuck on the horse and the horse
started freaking
out
a bunch of people well i think the
princesses or who are on horses
they're like trained so they know what
to do but then a bunch of people ran in
the child calm down the horse and it
took forever to calm it down
i'm like oh damn this is why kids suck
yeah
because right when the kid threw it you
hear like someone don't go oh come on
yeah well yesterday we were like uh
making dinner
and then taika comes out of nowhere and
he goes there's soy sauce on the carpet
and i'm like what that's such a clear
scent yeah like why
and then so we go and then so we bought
them a little kitchen set that's like
the size of this so i guess when we're
making food we didn't pay attention we
put
the soy sauce on uh the counter [ __ ]
and he took it off but i'm making
something with soy sauce too
yeah how cute he put it in his one of
his little pots that's in his
kitchen when he was pouring it he missed
it and it was like all over the [ __ ]
oh carpet yeah and i'm like [ __ ]
i'm like if i was my dad i would have
beat the living [ __ ] out of you
but then because i'm american and i
understand it's not your fault because i
want to be here
because i understand you're a child i'm
like oh help papa get some paper towels
that's really good that's good that he
told on himself yeah yeah yeah
he's being honest you gotta fix this
that's the problem with getting beat
though you don't want to tell
you're like who you become good liars
you're like
somebody the alien the
alien girl is is disneyland california
disneyland is not open right now right
no but they open for a little bit and i
think they just closed
no i think they opened no they were
planning to open as far as i know they
were planning to open
but then the cases kept rising so then
they decided not to open but they
i believe they did open downtown disney
for the restaurants
like for pickup and
does disney world have the churros
i bet they do i think they do they do
okay i'm going i'm gonna go
it's only shanghai disney that their
food
sucks really that's the one we haven't
been to the only one we're missing on
our list
yo the food is terrible is it american
style food
it's american style but just like
terrible like lunchables tastes better
they didn't try doing like chinese but
lunchables is like really good
they didn't try doing like the chinese
version like it's like the tokyo one
they have like bomb ass food there it's
like it's like a little japanese
orange very different it's very
different they got the churros of the
japanese one
yes yeah they had strawberries
strawberry churros
what about the french one um the paris
one
i don't remember i don't i didn't think
of the paris one being like this is the
dope disney
i really liked the castle though it was
so pretty it was so french i've been to
tokyo have you guys been to the sea one
no so all so that's my next my next goal
after because i i just want to see all
the castles around the world
that's why we went to magic so you want
to see all the castles the disney county
kings
i want to see some real castles in like
sky what's magic kingdom no so magic
kingdom is where they have the castle
it's all fantasy
whatever but but then like they have
animal kingdom epcot whatever there's
more
arts in disney world there's four parts
in disney world
it's bottom line yeah but then i need to
stay there for a month then
yeah that's what people do every
disneyland around the world they have
other parks like california adventure or
disney i didn't even know that
yeah so then my next goal is to go to
all those parks wow
i'll call two second class ones
they're actually a lot of people end up
liking them more because they have the
alcohol
i want to do all of that and then when i
had kids i'll be like
you got to pay for your own and go on
your own just fyi the change between
disney world and disneyland
to me is not as drastic as a change
between universal studios hollywood and
universal students orlando
by way of harry potter world oh really
you know harry potter world here the
soccer one
i have not oh because that's the only
harry potter world we saw
oh
all i know is that harry potter world
over here is like a it's like a postcard
of hogwarts right yeah but you go to
like orlando
and it's like the real freaking deal
it's huge
you know there's like knocks on out you
gotta like enter through like london
there's like a london cut out
so it's not it's not like it's not like
here's harry potter world it's like oh
this looks like london
you're like oh [ __ ] here's platform
ninety three quarters
yeah is it possible to go to disneyland
for
more than one day back to back because i
never did that every day that's the goal
actually yeah
when when they put you up out there or
when you go there the whole intention
is for your whole family to like stay at
the disneyland hotel you know what i
mean like
go to all four parks because they give
you like a discount for like every
single park
uh yeah park hoppers and stuff like that
so it's like it's yeah
you never need to leave the disney area
yeah you're supposed to just stay there
and just give them money because you can
you can eat it's like vegas yeah without
the hookers and the stinky
cigarettes children's version of vegan
family vegas but florida so anything can
happen
yeah yeah so you can still get the
hookers oh yeah
and covet apparently okay so bottom line
is that
uh it was they are claiming it's a nut
allergy reaction
uh leave us the [ __ ] alone because it
got to the point where
where the leave them alone they just
want their churros
yeah oh because the next day but if they
had corona then they're stupid the next
day they went to animal kingdom
after this uh she did a [ __ ] corona
test
they're like to take a corona virus test
because they're saying like why am i
gonna waste the test i'm healthy
this is clearly a reaction that's not
how it works
waste a test how do you like to like
someone else that needs it more than me
it's a [ __ ]
swab that cost about like 20 cents
shut the [ __ ] up i do not have any
symptoms
and i do not feel the need to waste the
test or their time i'm perfectly healthy
they're asymptomatic concepts but
anyways
that sounds like someone who just wants
to have fun and they don't want any of
the responsibilities and that's why
they're getting a lot of hate
um hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yup so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around around yeah you
can get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
[Music]
bye-bye
so